after a summer of expensive flights many
Americans are worried about the cost of
Holiday Travel the travel site Hopper
reports flying for Thanksgiving and
Christmas will be the most expensive
it's been in five years but there are
ways new ways to save Expedia is
revealing its annual air travel hacks
report and that is only on CBS mornings
right now it includes tips on the
cheapest days to travel and when you
should book CBS News senior travel
advisor Peter Greenberg got an early
look at it and he joins us right now
what's up Peter good morning good
morning everybody always has the news
let's jump right into it so what day
should you buy your plane ticket to get
the best deal well you know a couple of
years ago it was Tuesday at one minute
after midnight that it changed okay to
Friday now it's Sunday and the reason
why I changed the Sunday Expedia reports
that business travel is starting to come
back fares will stabilize on Sunday
you'll get the lowest deals then so you
log on you'll save about five percent on
domestic flights and an average of about
15 on International Affairs go Sunday so
buy it on Sunday right what day though
should you try to fly on to get the best
deals so not the day you buy it but the
day you actually travel well that's
another interesting story because it
changes based on the time of the year
right so for holiday travel this year
you don't want to travel on the
Wednesday before Thanksgiving right
right that makes it a movie like that
it's called Planes Trains and
Automobiles right so what you want to do
is go on the Friday before
or the day of for Christmas you want to
go the week before and you'll see before
absolutely yeah because remember
Christmas this year falls on a Sunday so
if you leave on the Friday before
Christmas you're not going to be in good
shape at all for fair people looking at
each other right now in the couch being
like your family's not coming a week
well don't even think about it or you do
what I do what do you do you fly on the
very first day of very first flight on
set on on Thanksgiving morning
get there in time to carve the turkey
and then while everybody's stuck at the
mall on Friday on Black Friday you go
home on Friday you can go bowling on
that day there's nobody on that planet
that makes sense right and you've
satisfied your family obligations and
and Nate you'll appreciate this the
weekend belongs to you now and you'll
watch as much bad football
are you talking about my Detroit Lions
let's not go there what
Flyers because I basically get a credit
card based on my frequent flyers sure I
use that for everything to build up the
miles well the problem with the frequent
flyer Awards right now is the Flames are
so full the airlines are not inclined to
give you those free frequent flyer
Awards seats right now although we are
in the fourth quarter and that's a
traditionally lower period of travel
they don't have to honor your freaking
flyer miles good luck redeeming them
these days you can't get on they don't
want to displace revenue passengers but
in the fourth quarter and going through
next may you can so think about 330 days
out be flexible but book them now
because the airlines continue to raise
the eligibility levels for the amount of
miles you have to reach that always bugs
me though when people say they don't
want to replace revenue passengers
because I had to pay to get those miles
yeah oh you had to pay a lot 54 of all
mileage earned is earned on the ground
with credit cards Gail yeah so that
might if you got a 25 000 mile award you
know what that means you spent fourteen
thousand dollars together don't tell me
that we talked about how to get deals
don't tell me that what about staff
shortages yeah how do you avoid the big
the biggest exactly yes well on the
Expedia report they figured out if
you've got a flight that leaves after
three o'clock in the afternoon it's 50
percent more likely to be canceled and a
whole lot more likely to be delayed so
that after three yeah so get an early
morning departure but that's that's
advice that we all can figure out the
first five day I go One Step Beyond that
what do you got pick a flight that First
Flight of the day on an airline that's
not based in the city where you're
flying from or where they don't have a
crew base and the reason for that is
that very first slide of the day had
come in the night before with that crew
I see what you do stays with the plane
that crew goes back with a plane and
you're on it you're gone but how do you
know the crew scheduled though Peter
very simple if you're flying out of
Chicago yeah you know what it's not
United it could be right if you're
flying out of Atlanta It's not Delta
it's United Peter Greenberg with the
hacks we appreciate you thank you so
much you got